straight to the Boscombe down re f base
where that aeroplane carrying 30 two
British and European evacuees from the
Diamond Princess cruise ship is arriving
after departing from Japan late last
night according to the Foreign Office
the evacuation flight also had British
government and medical staff on board
and passengers are then to be taken to
Arab Park Hospital on the rural for 14
days of quarantine but it's still
unclear where the small number of EU
citizens will be taken once the plane
arrives here in the UK the evacuees will
spend more than two weeks trapped on
that coronavirus stricken ship just off
the coast of Japan let's bring in our
correspondent Dan whiting he wasn't
there for us this morning
you can see the plane just coming in to
land here at Boscombe down in Wiltshire
that's plating that's come all the way
obviously from Japan on board 32 British
nationals along with a small number of
EU nationals and it has now landed here
at the Ministry of Defence Air Base much
relief of course for those British
nationals on board who as you say have
already been in isolation for 17 days on
board that cruise ship in Yokohama in
Japan the diamond princess very
difficult conditions for them here
they've been on that plane for 12 hours
also from Japan onboard the FCO consular
staff and medical staff who've been
keeping a really close eye just in case
anyone has fallen ill ill during the
flight we know that they have procedures
on board going back to the other
evacuation flights which have come into
the UK they have had procedures on board
to quarantine people on different parts
of the plane just in case they get ill
but that right now has landed here back
in the UK as a torso coach is lined up
they'll be getting on board those with
medical staff where they will then begin
the 4 to 5 hour drive up north to the
world and that is where their journey
will continue because they have to stay
there in quarantine for another 14 days
at the area Park Hospital that is where
they have got to stay in quarantine with
medical staff keeping a keen eye on
their condition to make sure that they
have not contracted kovat 19
you